with the transporter study vision van
Mercedes presents a new vehicle for the
final few kilometers of the delivery
process the electrically powered
automated and fully networked
transporter is part of Mercedes
strategic initiative titled advance this
is mercedes benz move from simply
manufacturing delivery vans to offering
integrated delivery system solutions the
vision van will be the first transporter
embodying an overall concept for a
completely digitally network process
chain stretching from warehouse to
recipient what's special about the
revolutionary study is it's completely
automated storage space where packages
are stowed and specifically assigned
spots autonomously flying drones speed
up deliveries they take off from the
roof and each can carry two kilos a
distance of up to ten kilometers the
vision van aims to reduce the time spent
at the curb and to bring customers their
goods at the time of day they desire if
possible on the date the order is made
thanks to its 75 kilowatt electric
engine with a range of up to 270
kilometers the vision van travels with
zero emissions that qualifies it to
drive in future urban zones that are
declared off-limits to conventional
internal combustion engines the nearly
silent electric van will also be able to
make deliveries at night without
disturbing the neighbors
the vision vans interior is designed
with the driver in mind he or she has
plenty of room because the cabin has no
central console pedals or steering wheel
the van is controlled with a joystick
warning signals on the flat floor light
up when pedestrians or bicycles are near
the van the driver can receive packages
in an ergonomically optimal position and
there's more if no aisle is needed in
the rear there is room for much more
cargo articles are scanned at the
warehouse and assigned a specific spot
in the van groups of 10 packages are
loaded into the vehicle via a mobile
conveyer belt
the navigation system shows the driver
the destinations and how many packages
he has to deliver to each the customer
receives a message when his delivery is
coming at each destination the cargo
area opens up a light signal shows which
articles to deliver and the driver takes
them without leaving the van if he or
she forgets a package there is an alert
that reduces the number of repeat trips
the door opens without a key short
distances and easy access to packages
make the deliveries job smoother time is
an important factor with cool products
they too can be quickly and accurately
delivered as the future van has separate
climate zones while it sparked a
luminous band on the vision vans rear
communicates with people in the
surroundings it tells how long it will
take to finish charging the batteries
warns about the drones flying around and
says when the driver will return or how
long the van will remain part
but it will be a number of years before
any of us actually encounter the vision
van on the street
you